pour moi c'est important puisque j'ai
des enfants ici les petits-enfants pour
eux il faut que l'avenir soit clair
qu'on sache exactement ce qu'on va
devenir
est ce qu'il va se passer après le moins
c'est très important souvent je vais ça
servait vous je vote blanc la france a
toujours été présente pour nous elle
restera je pense et je l'espère pourquoi
j'ai dit oui et bien je veux être libre
et je veux que ceux qui vont me
commander ce sera nos enfants du pays
voilà c'est quand même l'avenir de notre
pays de nos enfants etc mais voilà c'est
toute notre vie c'est le pour certains
c'est le combat d'une vie
et puis pour d'autres c'est le futur
comment faire à se penser tout ça donc
c'est important de participer à ce
référendum
aujourd'hui je vote oui metz pour
l'égalité pour le voir respect pour le
partage pour le vrai amour pour le
reportage